hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game that was played yesterday in
round three of the world junior
Championship it is a game between Han
smoke and Iman and Andy Woodward both of
them are Americans American Grandmaster
hunts versus American International
Master uh Andy Woodward this is the
first game I believe we are covering by
Andy Woodward on this channel and I
don't think we could uh cherry pick a
better one even if we tried as uh
probably you guys are wondering why is
Hans even playing in the world junior
Championship didn't he like the feet of
Vladimir karamnik you know with ease a
couple of days ago and you know he
crushes top tier players all the time
well yes but also the first prize is uh
3 000 Euros you also get a very nice
shiny Trophy and you also uh gets to be
called world champion so it's not not
bad plus also you get to see Mexico and
you might you're probably thinking about
Hans is like you know a thousand uh
rating points high rated than everyone
else not really he is the top seed but
he isn't uh all all that much higher
rated than everyone else here in this
game he faces Andy who is okay 200
rating points some 200 rating points
lower rated than Hans uh but uh it it is
a pretty much a series of the first
tough game for both of them so far they
faced um and a not so stronger
opposition but for for Andy this is uh
definitely a big as he is facing the top
tier player of the uh the top seed of
the tournament so let's check it out and
for those of you who played the ready
who played the English who transpose
into the English from the reti this will
be an absolute treat because this game
is like something from uh from a Paul
morphe era uh if you guys have problems
with English you definitely want to try
out this line so let's check it out uh
Hans has the white pieces and he opens
with Knight to F3 we have Knight to F6
and now Pawn to see for transposing into
the English we have G6 Knight to C3 and
Bishop to G7 so okay all very standard
stab you G6 finger of the bishop Knight
F6 Ponte E4 and now uh usually D6 and
castles are the most there that are
played here but we have Pawn to E5 it's
a very tricky idea and the problem for
white is that you you should you should
capture this point if you don't capture
it the black will consolidate it with D6
and black will have a an equal
possession a possession throughout the
entire game so a knight captures an E5
is by far the top move recommended by
the engine and of course Hans plays it
and uh the uh some other players that
have played this E5 line uh
vianiponoshi and of course Daniel dubo
so you know good things can come of it
so here we have castles uh and Knight
back to F3 as you know that now black
will pile up on this E4 Pawn so Rook to
E8 and D3 hunts defends it but now you
immediately strike in the center with
the D5 so okay you sacrifice the pawn
for material and the what comes next is
pretty straightforward and quite a lot
of theory behind it see captures on the
E5 Knight captures and D5 of course the
pawn is pinned and the bishop to D2 you
have to also add additional support to
the C for three nights so Bishop to G4
and the bishop to E2 now if Hans can
just castle and get a uh you know a move
to to breathe he will be perfectly fine
but of course Andy will not allow this
Knight to B4 puts pressure on the D3
Pawn so you have to move the bishop
Bishop to E3 now the pawn is defended by
the queen and by the bishop and now
Bishop captures an F3 this is how you
justify being down upon now white uh can
either give back the pawn which is not
recommended if you play Bishop captures
but you play G captures and now you get
this position where you keep defending
the pawn but you will not really be
castling kingside anytime soon or maybe
you will I will see what Hans does but
for the moment he's up a pawn and he
wants to enjoy his spawn for the rest of
the game and he is the higher rated
opponent so he should prove that this is
okay for white so knight uh eight uh to
C6 continuing development and now there
is a game where A3 was played but Hans
plays Pawn to H4 now interestingly A3
and pawn to H4 are the two top engine
moves and I've even allowed the engine
to Crunch the numbers like the depth 50
and the engine goes for Pawn to H4 so
Hans definitely knows this line and he
knows uh how to properly play it so it
is now as of move 13 then we have a
completely new game Knights to D4 again
with a threat of knights of the sea to
check winning material so of course Hans
has to do something about that he plays
Brook to C1 and now Queen to D6 nicely
developing the queen connecting the roxa
and its hands to move he plays Spawn to
A3 says alright I'm not just gonna allow
your Knights to remain so active here
Knight the A6 and now we have Pawn to F4
Hans just continues playing like nothing
is happening here we have Rook 8 to d8
and now Pawn to B4 uh of course
occupying the most important Square on
the board while preventing knight from
coming into the game via the C5 Square
so uh Andy will have to play C5 himself
with Ponte if you could Advance the pawn
to B5 right now but first he grabs more
space by attacking the queen queen to E7
and now Pawn to B5 we have knighted to
C7 and now uh the again I had to Crunch
the numbers because I have no idea what
is happening here uh the the top moves
here are Knights the E4 which of course
makes sense uh other idea you might come
to is King to F1 because the king is
very vulnerable and E1 and the other one
is Pawn to H5 just starting an attack on
the king's side however Hans played
Queen to A4 here and here he already
starts uh uh getting into a little bit
of trouble we have Queen to E6 now
preparing Queen to F5 to go after the D3
pawn and now comes Bishop to D1 here the
the way to play this is not to wait for
black to do something as you do have a
king and E1 is to play H5 and now the
point is after let's say G5 you will
play captures and after Bishop captures
on E5 now you play Queen to C4 which is
a bit different than what happened in
the game now if Queen to F5 you will
simply play Pawn to G6 and already your
attack is happening a little bit faster
than Black's attack but after Queen T6
hunts played Bishop to D E1 again a very
useful move very nicely controls the
Knight here all of the squares and you
are preventing anything from coming to
B3 but it allows Queen to F5 the bishop
no longer guards the D3 Pawn so you have
to do something about that Queen to C4
was played and now comes Bishop to H6
just piling up on the entire position
there's no other way to call this uh
it's uh it's really something you would
expect in a in in a morphe game Knights
the E4 by Hans going for that Knight to
F6 check but now Bishop captures an F4
gramming upon Knight to F6 with check
King to G7 and even the Knight captures
on E8 so now Hans even wins The Exchange
Rook capture 78 and queen captures on C5
now attacking the Knight on C7 and Andy
plays Knight captures on B5 and now how
do you continue here Hans is now up the
exchange but he is the one under
pressure both the both of the knights
are here the bishop is here the queen is
here the The Rock occupies the same file
as hans's king so uh what can you do it
seems like you could win some material
here but not really Bishop captures on
D4 Knight captures on D4 and queen
captures there's Bishop captures on E5
now threatening all sorts of nasty
discoveries and look at this if Queen to
E4 offering a queen trade and okay it
looks like you cannot move the bishop
because the rokaneate is hanging there
is a there's Bishop to G3 absolutely
incredible now you cannot take the queen
because uh you would be in check and you
cannot take the Rook because you would
be in Checkmate so that's kind of the
problem here you're gonna have to play
Rook to F1 give up the queen and with it
the game so after this Knight C captures
on B5 move hunt said all right I'm just
gonna get my king away from the middle
of the board he castles Here and Now
Rook captures on E5 attacks the White
Queen Bishop captures on D4 now Hans
tries to give up uh his own Queen but of
course black cannot capture as The Rook
here is pinned so Knight captures on D4
and now Queen capture Sandy for
continuing to pin The Rook here Bishop
captures and C1 you have to play this
otherwise you're just gonna be down
material and here Rook to E1 now this is
the absolute best move and it seems like
Hans got away with it uh he's uh he he
gave back the The Exchange and he
equalizes the material he's still down a
pawn but he is surviving and he's
threatening to win a full Rook here so
Bishop to F4 and the defense and now
comes Rook to E4 and it seems like uh
Andy should be uh close to resigning now
because the the bishop is saying you
can't really defend the bishop if you
move the bishop then you're gonna lose
the Rook uh but the problem is uh it's
actually Hans who is lost here so feel
free to pause the video and try to find
the absolute best move for Andy while I
give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on uh finding this
incredible move and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is Queen
to F6 believe it or not this actually
works it's the first mood that I thought
of but I uh then I immediately said no
of course that there's a no way because
after you you captured there's just no
good follow-up but there is if Rook
captures an F4 Rook to E1 check is uh
actually quite okay after King to G2
Queen characters throw characters and
Road captures on D1 you're up a pawn
with a much better position A3 uh D3 and
F2 and H4 are all isolated pawns black
the black has only two Pawn Islands
white has four Pawn islands and as black
is up upon this uh if played the
Perfection probably black will win this
but Hans did not want to go for this he
probably wanted to keep chances alive he
played Pawn to H5 and now comes Rook the
G5 with check King to F1 and now even
Bishop to F Bishop to E5 attacking the
queen here Queen capture Sunny 7 other
moves are really we are not helping
hands and now uh Pawn to B6 this is the
sort of the the final nail in the coffin
of this game as it prevents the White
Queen from uh helping out with the
defense of the pawn here so Queen to A8
trying to get the Rook into the game and
maybe even Checkmate the black king
somehow but now G captures on H5 uh Rook
to E3 now freeing up this diagonal for
the White Queen and now Bishop to H2
going for Rook to G1 check so Rook the
EA trying to go for Rook to G8 check but
now Rook to G1 this comes with check
King E2 we have King to H6 even uh
wasting a move for this because there is
no counter play and the problem is while
D4 is very nice and it opens up so all
sorts of possibilities uh including this
diagonal uh the problem is after Queen
captures on the four and queen the C6
check you can play King to G7 and die
after Bishop to C2 uh the simple Queen
to G4 check is enough and after King to
D2 you can can even play the well just
the awkward Bishop to E5 uh not allow
any checks along this diagonal the
bishop is now very nicely controlling it
you cannot capture with the Rook because
of Queen to D4 check picking up the rook
and now you have to worry about
um a lot of stuff here but your king
will not survive in the center of the
board so after King to H6 Bishop the C2
was played by Hans right away but it is
not enough Queen to C3 by Andy going
after the bishop Rook to see a defending
and attacking and now Rook to E1 with
check King F3 and queen to F6 with check
going for the sort of a ladder Checkmate
here King to G2 now comes Rook to G1
check and he was in this position on
move 42 that Han smoker Neiman resigned
the game as there is nothing more to be
done here now uh the the problem is of
course the ones you capture Queen
captures and F2 check happens and after
the king moves Queen to G3 will be
Checkmate so really a wild game where
both players play the uh at an
incredible accuracy I know that uh okay
if you if you're into that thing I think
Andy's accuracy was calculated some
maybe even 98 90 97.3 or something like
that but I I believe even uh Hondas
would be like maybe 90 90 something so
funds didn't commit any any murders here
or any any you know critical critical
mistakes it was just that uh Andy played
it that much better in any critical
position that was
um yeah that happened on the board he
just played a perfect game here and the
Hans paid the ultimate price so a
brilliant victory for Andy uh let me
just check who Andy is um uh facing next
uh so we see what we are dealing with
here
uh sorry about that so Andy uh uh Mark
Andrea maurizi is uh from France is his
next opponent and I I have no idea where
Hans is uh Andy is on three other three
let me just check
who Hans is facing next he's currently
31st and he will be facing Juan
Sebastian million
uh from Paraguay but yeah I mean an
incredible game where you really uh you
really think okay Hans will just cruise
through this uh world world junior
Championship uh you know just you know
destroying everyone uh but not really
you know you face Andy Woodward here he
plays the perfect game and you you just
get absolutely destroyed here so uh I
mean up to this point where it is it's a
known position and eighth reason on move
Hans plays the absolute strongest move
recommended by the engine H4 uh so he is
not surprised by this or maybe he found
the top move over the board doesn't
really matter he had a you know an
excellent position and the playable one
uh but you can see just how difficult it
is the to play this with the ruined Pawn
structure with your king in the center
of the board so if you if you have
problems playing against English maybe
try employing this line so it's not
really okay this is a transposed English
but uh E5 if wine doesn't capture any
five you've already equalized if y does
capture yes you you're down upon but all
all of the moves that follow are so
active and so
um so enjoyable to play like night
before then you threaten here then you
you just keep developing it so so nice
to play the moves come naturally and
especially for like a blitz and bullet
uh I mean you guys should really try
this uh so yeah that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it we'll see what happens
will Hans be able to recover from this
and is he still in contention for for
the uh top uh uh top prize in this world
junior Championship or will someone else
become world champion we'll see what
happens I would like to wish a very
happy birthday to Carlos Carla and I
would like to thank Paul Miller Kenneth
Frazier aludian Ralph and Nick met in
Yasser for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here and thank you for watching
and I will see you soon continuing to
check up any wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the Chess World
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day